in your fighting career where you're
more
motivated by the love of winning
or the fear and hatred of losing
i like to win better than i hate to lose
because if it would not have been the
case
i would never have fought in the first
place because i don't like
to fight at all but you talked about the
anxiety
the fear the experience leading up to a
fight so
to you ultimately the reason to go
through that
difficult process is because it feels
damn good to have your hand raised
there is that there is also the fact
that
martial art had been introduced when i
was very young
and it's probably the best thing i can
do in my life
fighting is it's that's what i do best
also it provides me of
freedom of access of things that
most of people do not have um
but all that as a price and a lot of
money i made a lot of money of course
with it
i was maybe predisposed with certain
abilities
i met incredible mentors
throughout my life i worked really hard
and of course i had a lot of chances the
the stars were all aligned
and in order to to
kept keep that those advantages
of freedom money and glory and excess of
things that most people don't have and
have the
these dream life that i have
i had to sacrifice myself and fight in
order to keep it
it's very hard to understand because i
also believe most fighters are not like
me
they a lot of guys because i corner a
lot of guys
and it seems to me that they love their
job they enjoyed
to to go fight in a cage i love to train
i love the
science of fighting the sport the
to to be in good shape the confidence
that training in mixed martial art
give me however i do not like the
feeling
of uncertainty the stress that i have
not knowing if i will be badly injured
or humiliated or
winning the fight it's to me unbearable
and
that's what takes the most out of me
more than
brain damage more than anything that's
what takes the most out of me
but the thing you get from it is the
freedom that you
get because uh because of the money but
because of the celebrity because of
everything that comes with it
so you can be the best version of
yourself because of fighting
you